melina is a mysterious character that we
all welcome with open arms as soon as
she gives us the ability to level up our
character and gives us the spectral
steed whistle through summon torrent so
that we can travel around easier and
faster maybe she noticed that we were
struggling a bit before we found a place
to rest so that she could offer us
something that we truly could not refuse
she offers herself to play the role of
maiden on her journey to the elden ring
basically after being told that we have
no girlfriend and likely never will by
vary you are maidenless we take the
offer without any hesitation go back to
varet and laugh in his face melna will
then join us on our quest to the capital
city where she'll give us helpful hints
on the lore of queen america in certain
churches spread around the lands between
and send us to the round table where we
can meet other tarnished characters
learn what we need to do to progress
upgrade our weapons and gear and get
lots of hugs even though we damn well
know that fia gives us a debuff to our
health in this world you just need a hug
sometimes melano will be with us
spiritually on our path until we reach
the capital city where she tells us that
she can now move freely on her own and
says her goodbyes which i don't know
about you guys kind of hurt my feelings
initially finally you make your way to
the door of the tree where we battle
against morgot and we can summon melina
into the fight to make things easier but
after defeating him you find that the
door is blocked off by impenetrable
thorns then melania has the great idea
of burning the entire her tree down
where you might think this may be a
little extreme but screw it as long as i
can have my maiden back she gives you
the rolled medallion where you travel to
the grand lift of world to be taken to
the mountaintops of the giants where you
defeat the fire giant and continue to
the forge of the giants where melania
sacrifices herself to burn the earth
tree down so that you can become elden
lord but you are now yet again
maidenless now let me bring up something
i find interesting you go on this long
journey with melana so that she can be
sacrificed to serve as kindling to burn
the urgery down but if given the option
to spare her and instead use yourself
and the flame of frenzy as kindling she
says if you do that should you rise as
the lord of chaos
i will kill you
as sure as night follows day so okay the
flame of frenzy must be bad if melano
doesn't like it i also got that
impression from this guy pretty clearly
oh
may chaos take
the world
may chaos
take
the world and if you go ahead and do it
anyway she won't kill you but make you
feel really bad about yourself and just
leaves now if you want to revert this
decision you need to consume nicolas
needle in the boss room of dragon lord
placidusax this item reads one of the
unalloyed gold needles that mikala
crafted to ward away the meddling of the
outer gods so what does this tell us
well for starters that the flame of
frenzy is an outer god that either is
the three fingers or took over the three
fingers before it was hidden away deep
below the capital city and two melania
doesn't care if you reverse this ending
she does not forgive you for not using
her as kindling at the forge of the
giants you'd think she'd be pretty happy
that she doesn't you know have to die
but she still doesn't forgive you you
obviously don't get the ending where she
turns into the glomide queen where
she'll hunt you down and deliver you
destin death that's only if you become
the lord of chaos but even after the
reversal she still never shows herself
again to you which i think gives us the
answer to what is melano's purpose it is
to serve as kindling to burn down the
earth tree that is it that's all she
wants because her main goal is to fix
the lands between
i have long observed the lands between
this world is in dire need of repair
and death
indiscriminate
now i've made a couple other videos on
some theories about melna there's the
theory that melanon and ronnie are the
same person just with two different
consciousnesses there's also the theory
that melna is the glomide queen mostly
suggested from the flame of frenzy
ending and the color change of her eyes
either one of those theories could be
true we aren't meant to know for sure
just like all of elden ringlor but after
researching more on melina i still
firmly believe that she is the glomide
queen and is somehow related to queen
merica whether being one of her
forgotten children or some other weird
elden ring incest thing that's hard to
understand we know that queen america
was chosen by the greater will to be the
vessel of the elden ring but eventually
america was driven to the brink whatever
that means and shattered the elden ring
but was half mended and repaired by
ratagon i think this driven to the brink
was that america was struggling to feed
the earth tree the archery feeds on
struggle so america needs us the
tarnished and all the people of the
lands between to struggle so that the er
tree can grow stronger this is why she
sends her lord consort godfrey outside
the lands between because they ran out
of people to battle against they were
sent so that they could continue to
struggle die and feed the er tree grow
strong in the face of death
warriors of my lord
lord godfrey
now i want you to look at this image of
the hand of the elden beast and then i
want you to look at melania's left eye
looks pretty familiar to me like the
claw of the elden beast is branded to
her eye so what does this mean like i
said before melania's entire purpose is
to fix the lands between to have us the
tarnished mend the elden ring so that
death can be restored to the world
otherwise known as destined death to
deliver you what is yours
destined death
but if she were to shatter the elden
ring and remove the rune of death people
would just come back to life and
continue to struggle over and over again
constantly feeding the earth tree so
then we defeat ratagon and are
introduced to the elden beast after
melina either speaks to her mother or is
just inspired by what she sees inside
the earth tree she realizes that the
lands between needs death back and
obviously the greater will would want
death to be mended back into the elden
ring as well this is where the glomide
queen comes back into play she was once
the protector of the rune of death when
the ring was shattered america ordered
malakath to take the rune of death from
melana and seal it away malakath
defeated melana and sealed destin death
away into the medallion you see on his
hand melano only returns to the world
when ronnie steals a fragment of the
rune of death from malakath when ronnie
uses half this fragment to kill her body
and the other half to kill godwin's soul
otherwise known as the knight of black
knives a fragment of the glomide queen
or melina is released back into the
world this makes more sense when melina
tells us that she can freely move on her
own when you reach the capital city
she's closer to the elden ring and the
greater will so she starts to become
more powerful as she gets closer to it
essentially melana is the rune of death
or at least an essence or protector of
it the greater will needs the elden ring
to be mended and when melana is released
back into the world she will do anything
to have us the tarnished mend the elden
ring and become the new elden lord
that's why as soon as she sees us
struggling she wants to help us on her
path that's why she tests us before
sending us to the roundtable hold
forgive me
i've been
testing you
to see whether or not grace truly does
guide you
and
whether you are fit to face the
challenge that entails
she's basically been looking for a
tarnish that's strong enough to take
this difficult journey to becoming elden
lord because she needs us to take her to
the forge of giants to serve as kindling
mend the elden ring become elden lord
and fix the lands between
[Music]
thank you
for guiding me here
[Music]
the one who walks alongside flame
shall one day meet the road of destined
death
goodbye
thank you all for watching the video i
hope you enjoyed it and let me know what
you think in the comments make sure to
subscribe is only six percent of people
who watch my videos are actually
subscribed i've had to give my dog joy
over 20 000 tummy rubs for all the
support over the past month on the
channel so she and i thank you all very
much have a great rest of your day and i
will see you all in the next video take
care